- This video is brought to you
by Full Sail University.
(soft upbeat music)
What's up everybody?
Michael here.
Now, today, we're talking about the show
that's convinced me to never attend
a superhero orgy ever,
no matter what.
This most recent season
of "The Boys" has been
both chaotic and wildly compelling.
And if Homelander's recent
antics have shown us anything,
it's that Kanye was right:
No one man should have all that power.
But it's not just Homelander
and his new radioactive daddy
whose lives are defined by power,
it's all of them.
Whether they're as helpless as Huey
or as formidable as Starlight,
every single player is being forced
to play the same power game.
So why are all of these characters
so obsessed with power,
and can the power struggles
in The Boys teach us something
about how power functions
in our own societies?
Let's find out with a little help
from some French philosophers.
Frenchie would be so proud of us.
- (speaking foreign language)
- Welcome to this Wisecrack
edition on The Boys,
"Is Power Going To Kill Us All?"
And of course, major spoilers ahead
for the latest season of The Boys.
But before we get into it,
I wanna shout out this video's sponsor,
Full Sail University.
Full Sail offers associates,
bachelors, and master's degrees
in the fields of technology, arts,
media, and entertainment.
And they just launched
a new bachelor's degree
in game business and eSports,
which can help students enter the industry
from different perspectives.
From game development,
to communications and marketing,
to competitive gaming itself.
And this new major joins a roster
of other cool fields of study,
like film production, computer animation,
sportscasting, and web development.
With Full Sail University's
accelerated coursework,
you can finish your degree in about half
the time required at other
colleges and universities.
Plus, you can complete your classes
and coursework online
or in-person at Full
Sail's campus in Orlando,
depending on what's right for you.
Whatever model you choose,
you'll get hands on, real world experience
in the career path of your choice.
Plus, Full Sail accepts
new enrollments monthly
so you don't have to build your schedule
around traditional semesters.
To learn more about Full Sail University's
new game business and eSports majors,
or any of their other degree programs,
visit fullsail.edu/wisecrack.
That's fullsail.edu/wisecrack.
And now, back to the show.
The Boy puts power front and center.
Since we're dealing with a world
where some people can leap buildings,
or obliterate an innocent woman,
in a single bound.
But just as importantly,
a whole lot of people can't.
And all of this sounds in line
with Michel Foucault's analysis
of how power functions in society.
One form of power he
identifies, sovereign power,
describes the right of those
at the top to give and take life,
or, to put it more simply,
the right to kill.
We see a lot of this in
modern political philosophy.
In this view of power,
there's a small contingent at the top
who can take all of us out at will
and then we're just down at the bottom,
hoping that they don't.
And ever since A-Train plowed
through Huey's girlfriend
and Homelander took out an entire plane
to protect the company,
The Boys has been exploring how dangerous
this type of sovereign power really is
and how those who wield it
rarely face consequences.
This is why, at least initially,
it seems like we're
watching a valiant quest
by Butcher and the boys
to level the playing field
by overthrowing the supes
and the force of their sovereign power.
But as we go further down
the Vought rabbit hole,
it becomes clear that the
power problem isn't limited
to the wielding of power
by a powerful sovereign,
a la what Hobbes
and the modern political
philosophers talked about.
Rather, power is more defined
by what Foucault describes as,
"Rules according to which the
true and false are separate
"and specific effects of power
"which are attached to the true.
"A battle about the status of truth
"and the economic and
political role it plays."
In this way, power is something
that's sort of everywhere,
and enacted more than it's possessed.
The boys are on a
mission to prevent anyone
from wielding that type
of power ever again.
But as we go further down
the Vought rabbit hole,
it becomes clear that the
power problem isn't limited
to A-Train and co, it's everywhere.
Along with Starlight,
Huey has been the closest thing
the show has to a moral compass.
We sympathize with him
because he's been victimized
by multiple members of The Seven,
and he's way more compassionate
than most of the show's alpha males.
Plus, he's just sort of adorable
and wears really great T-shirts,
but he still lives in a world
where value is measured in power.
And the A-Train action figures
in his bedroom show us
that he grew up admiring supes.
He desires power
but has spent most of his life without it,
and the tension this creates
soon starts bubbling
up in unpleasant ways,
some of which involve intravenous drug use
and green puke.
Now, Huey's frustration seems
to come from a good place.
He's watched his loved ones being harmed
without being able to help
so he wishes he was stronger,
but there's something else going on
and it manifests in his
insecurity about dating a supe.
The struggle to open a jar threatens
his sense of manhood,
even when they're safe at home.
On some level,
Huey feels entitled to be
more powerful than Starlight
simply because he's a man.
His sense of worth is derived
from how powerful he feels,
specifically relative to his
incredibly powerful girlfriend.
- I thought that you
didn't care about that.
I mean, on our first date,
you said that it didn't bother you.
- I know.
But it does.
Sometimes.
- [Michael] But this
isn't just a Huey problem.
Society prioritizes power,
which we see in the throngs
of sad sacks obsessed with Homelander,
all getting off on his
all-encompassing power.
This seemingly harmless
but toxic dude-ness is
exemplified by Todd,
a classic nice guy type.
He's a glasses-wearing,
flannel shirt-clad teacher,
and caring stepfather and husband.
But we learn that underneath
the nice guy exterior is
a dark obsession with Homelander
and his most toxic and violent beliefs.
- 'Cause he's America's greatest hero
who saves thousands of people.
He's standing up to the crooks,
the corporations, and the legacy media.
Hey, you friend me on Facebook,
I'll send you some stuff.
- And I mean...
Okay, let's just say it right now.
In particular, in season three,
they're doing a Trump thing.
I mean, you saw the
taco bowl scene, right?
- Seriously, we have the best taco bowls
right here in the building.
Should make you feel right at home, pal.
(speaking foreign language)
- Trump literally did that.
And the whole, "I could
shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
"and nothing would happen" thing.
- Where I could stand in the middle
of Fifth Avenue and shoot somebody,
and I wouldn't lose any voters, okay?
- [Michael] Well, that happens too.
And it goes just about as well
as old Don Sr. predicted.
- Yeah!
(crowd applauding)
- [Michael] And while
Huey doesn't have Todd's
dark obsession with
Homelander's fascist worldview,
he does fall into the same trap
of being the nice guy
who fetishizes the power of others.
The introduction of Temp V allows Huey
to experience the physical power
that A-Train and Homelander have used
to ruin his life,
and the transformation is stunning.
Formerly peaceful,
Huey starts killing people
with his bare hands
while naked.
- Oh (beep), I'm sorry.
- If I was murdered by
a fully clothed man,
I would feel a sense of honor.
If I was murdered by a naked person,
I would feel shame.
I'd feel nothing 'cause I'd be dead
but assuming that the afterlife exists
and consciousness transcends
into the afterlife,
I would feel shame.
We can better understand
what's going on here
with another type of power
that Foucault talks about:
Biopower.
Foucault describes it as
"An explosion of numerous
and diverse techniques
"for achieving the subjugation of bodies
"and the control of populations."
Biopower is another mechanism
by which societies can control
who lives or dies
while ensuring the health
of a stable workforce.
This can look like, I don't know,
like governments deciding when life begins
and what bodies containing
life are allowed
to do with them.
Sorry, I know that was a
super hypothetical example.
I'll do a better one next time.
And in the world of The Boys,
both Compound V and Temp
V represent advances
in a type of biopower
by which certain humans literally have
more biological power,
which they can decide to use
to hurt or to help people.
So Huey's pacifism, empathy,
and loyalty to Starlight all dwindle
as soon as he is jacked up on that V.
It's almost as if he was just using
these virtues as crutches that,
once empowered, he no longer found useful.
- I thought the drugs had
(beep) you up, Huey, but
this is you.
This is all you.
- [Michael] Luckily, by
the end of the season,
we learned that Huey isn't, in fact,
a total power hungry piece of (beep).
- Literally, every neuron
in your brain is screaming
"I told you so,"
so why don't you just say it
before your head explodes?
- Oh my God!
I (beep) told you so.
- But not everyone comes back to the light
after tasting some power.
And power dynamics aren't
exclusive to the men.
The show's female characters
also find themselves forced
to compromise their values
if they want to enjoy agency or authority.
Take the shameless
corporate climber, Ashley.
- I accept your nomination as CEO
of Vought International.
You know, my mother used to say,
before she died of cancer when I was 17--
- Okay, Ashley, that's enough.
Let's not bring the room down.
- Apologies, sir.
- [Michael] Having worked
her way to the top at Vought,
she gets a front row seat
to Homelander's brutal corporate culture.
But being humiliated every day
by those above her doesn't inspire Ashley
to change the system
or challenge its legitimacy,
though it does lead to her
ripping out her own hair.
Instead, she just soaks up all their abuse
and unleashes it on those
not as strong as her.
- The next report you're gonna be doing is
inside my (beep) asshole...
- [Michael] Putting women like Ashley
in positions of power seems like
it should challenge the
patriarchal culture at Vought.
That, at least, is the theory
of the "Lean In" brand of feminism,
sometimes called "corporate feminism,"
which has been championed by the likes
of former Facebook COO, Sheryl Sandberg.
The thinking goes that women climbing
the ranks can change
things from the inside,
tipping the balance and
fundamentally altering
sexist power structures.
Unlike most third wave feminists,
corporate feminism doesn't view capitalism
as part and parcel with gender inequality.
Rather, it argues that equality comes
when capitalism diversifies.
It's sort like saying that
the planet of Alderaan would still exist
if the Death Star were pink.
In reality, and much like Ashley,
Sandberg's been accused
of wielding her power
in less than savory ways.
She reportedly yelled at
and intimidated employees
when they tried to speak up
about Facebook's role in Russia's campaign
to influence the 2016 election,
and she reportedly
failed to act decisively
to stop the prolific dissemination
of right wing extremism, racism,
and misogyny on the platform.
But to be clear,
to the best of our knowledge,
Sandberg has never been complicit
in any murders or kidnapping
that we're aware of.
On the show, Ashley embraces
a type of "Lean In" feminism,
even as she's actively harming
the women around her.
She ends up mimicking
Homelander's example.
- Is your idiot brain
getting (beep) by stupid?
- [Michael] Several other
female characters do the same.
Before Homelander went
all "Raiders of the Lost Ark" on her,
Madelyn Stillwell was able to hold
some sway over the superpowered man-baby,
but only by indulging
his edible fantasies.
Our boy likes to drink that milk.
Also, in this season,
he milks a cow to suck its teat
'cause his edible fantasies transition
to farm animals,
but we don't kink-shame at Wisecrack.
- Nope.
- And Madelyn had no qualms
with all types of murder
and intimidation and bribery,
as long as it helped her climb
the corporate ranks.
Even superpowered women are forced
to occupy a specific version
of the "strong woman" archetype.
When she joins The Seven,
Starlight's costume is
immediately reinvented
to make it more revealing.
You know, for the fellas.
She can be strong,
just as long as she's also sexy.
And while Vought goes out of its way
to highlight how empowered
its female heroes are
with their "Girls get it done" slogan...
- Girls get it done.
- [Michael] They always ensure that
their vision of a powerful
woman does nothing
to challenge the authority
of the patriarchy.
- Wow, I'm so honored to
be with you guys tonight
to celebrate my dear friend
and mentor, Homelander.
- [Michael] Even when
they seem to be acting
outside the bounds of
conventional gender roles,
they're still just playing with power.
- (indistinct)
- [Michael] Stormfront's
whole identity was based
around rejecting the
traditional feminine qualities
of someone like Starlight.
- (beep) this world for
confusing nice with good.
Be a bitch if you want, be whatever,
just drop the mask once in a while.
- [Michael] But this "not
like other girls" branding was
only skin deep
because her casual Nazism still comes
in a conventionally feminine package.
- Yay.
- It's a lot like the
"cool girl" archetype
from "Gone Girl,"
where her subversions are acceptable
in so much as they don't
challenge gender roles themselves.
Also, at the end of the day,
she still ends up being
Homelander's half-dead HJ machine.
- When you lead an army
of Aryan ubermensch
to their victory.
- What?
- The key thing here is that no matter
how high any of them climb,
the moment they stop playing along
with the powers that be,
the moment they improperly
express empathy,
they can be easily thrown under the bus,
or tossed into a secret prison,
or just taken out all together.
This makes any kind of
solidarity almost impossible.
Vought takes full advantage
of the women's disunity
when it wants to get rid of Queen Maeve.
While positioning her as a symbol
of empowered queer womanhood
was great for marketing,
the moment she starts to speak out,
she vanishes.
And when Starlight appeals
to Ashley's humanity
to try and find her,
we see a split second of empathy,
and then...
- I am CEO.
Next time, make a (beep) appointment.
- From soft boys like Huey
to superwomen like Starlight,
what the third season of the show
really underlines is how difficult it is
to actually take a stand against
the types of power that philosophers
like Foucault talk about.
When describing his theory of biopower,
he says that "If genocide is indeed
"the dream of modern power,
"this is not because of the recent return
"to the ancient right to kill.
"It is because power is situated
"and exercised at the level of life,
"the species, the race,
"and the large scale
phenomena of the population."
Which means that modern power uses
as much force as necessary to maintain
the structure of a governable society.
- Nobody wants innocent people
to get hurt, of course not.
But sadly,
well, the bad guys,
they don't think like us.
And so, sometimes,
well, these things just happen.
- Now, we can better understand
what's going on here by visiting
another pair of French thinkers,
Gilles Deleuze and Félix Guattari,
who we would assume Frenchie has
definitely read while in
a philosophical K-hole.
- You know, Jean-Paul Sartre said,
"Marriage stifles our
essential male urges."
- Their work understands modern power
via the lens of capitalism,
and how human desire is structured
and then used by capitalism.
This allows them to analyze
how capitalism seems
to be able to suck everything up
into its own orbit,
infinitely increasing its
own power and control.
According to Deleuze,
"Everything is rational in capitalism
"except capital or capitalism itself.
"The stock market is certainly rational.
"One can understand it, study it,
"the capitalists know how to use it,
"and yet it is completely delirious.
"It's mad.
"It is in the sense that we say
"the rational is always the rationality
"of an irrational."
This is a key tension of
how power operates under capitalism.
It makes logical sense,
i.e we can understand how markets
and profits work in mathematical terms,
but it's also totally batshit
when we realize
how these logical systems
affect society and human life.
It makes logical sense
that student loan debt comes
with compounding interest,
but it makes absolutely no sense
that a kindergarten teacher
can rack up six figures
in growing debt.
And we see this in Vought,
a publicly traded corporation
that makes logical decisions based on
how it affects the market
and their profitability,
even when the reality of
those decisions involves
murdering innocent humans,
or experimenting on children,
and empowering a superpowered psychopath.
It's what makes Homelander
such a perfect metaphor
for this kind of capitalist-fueled power.
He's literally bulletproof,
able to shrug off any attack,
any criticism,
any call for accountability,
because at the end of the day,
he still has all the power.
And as long as his
power doesn't contradict
the logic of capital,
everything is fine.
And that's what people who really want
to change things are up against.
A powerful structure that can
logically justify taking you out
if you're (beep) with their profits,
and that has the biopower
to kill you with ease.
Take the three characters
who seemed like they were leading
the charge against Vought and Homelander:
Starlight, Billy Butcher,
and Victoria Neuman.
They're each taking different approaches
to changing things,
with Butcher aiming for
a violent insurrection,
Neuman hoping to bring
about political change
via the democratic process,
and Starlight trying to
fix Vought from the inside.
Now, initially, it seems like
they're all making a difference:
Butcher is effectively tracking down
dangerous superheroes while reining in
his most violent impulses;
Neuman is leading the
Bureau of Superhero Affairs
to try and keep those with powers
within the bounds of the law;
and Starlight has been made co-captain
of the The Seven,
seemingly putting her on equal footing
with Homelander.
It looks like real change is coming,
but that idea is quickly set on fire,
snapped in half,
and stomped into the dirt,
and then it gets its head blown up.
Neuman is revealed to
be in Vought's pocket.
This makes sense as the
corporation is so powerful
that it can own everyone
on both sides of the political divide,
propping up progressive politicians
to maintain the impression
of a functioning democracy
without risking Vought's own authority.
Oh, and Neuman is, of course, also a supe
who can blow people's heads up.
But hey, at least this is just a TV show.
It's not like corporate
interest would ever have
a direct relationship
with seemingly progressive
politicians that...
That allowed them to ensure
that they stayed in power
while pacifying the masses
into thinking that politicians
were fighting for them,
'cause that'd be crazy, right?
Like, if politicians took money
from the oil industry,
the weapons industry,
the tech industry,
and then they were like,
"Oh no, but we care.
"We care about you," you know?
That's TV stuff, okay?
Grow up if you think
that's how the world works,
that's TV.
It's not how the world works.
For Deleuze and Guattari,
none of this fundamentally contradicts
how capital works
because ideology doesn't really matter,
only power does.
Deleuze says in an interview that,
"ideology has no importance whatsoever.
"What matters is not ideology,
"not even the
economic-ideological distinction
"or opposition,
"but the organization of power.
"Because organization of power,
"that is the manner in which desire is
"already in the economic,
"in which libido invests the economic,
"haunts the economic
"and nourishes political
forms of repression."
Okay, this means that underneath
a social performance of
ideology and politics,
like what we see from Neuman,
is really just a raw desire for power.
- You've 193 million Instagram followers.
Lend me your influence
and I'll lend you mine.
I can protect you from Homelander,
you'll finally be team captain for real.
And in return, you'll
help me goose my numbers.
- [Michael] This isn't
just about one politician
secretly being corrupt,
but a system where power is
so concentrated into the hands
of corporations like Vought
that no one can even enter the game
without their say-so.
Huey might have thought that
he and Neuman were making
all the right chess moves
to take Vought down,
but it turns out Vought
owned the whole board
from the beginning
and Neuman was playing along
because she gets that it's about power
and not ideology.
The same goes for Starlight.
Going from a simple country girl
to the head of the executive table,
she's exactly the sort of success story
that "Lean In" feminism craves;
Living proof that talented
and committed women can smash
through the glass ceiling
and rise to the top.
Of course, it's quickly revealed
that Vought is still underpinned
by the same values it always was,
namely that they'll say and do
whatever makes their stock price go up.
Feminism is useful if it's profitable
and helps them sell merch,
and that's about it.
- We always seem primed
to celebrate individual advancements,
individual advancements of black people,
people of color, women,
without taking into consideration
that diversity by itself may simply mean
that previously marginalized
individuals have been recruited
to guarantee a more efficient operation
of oppressive systems.
- [Michael] On the back
of numerous scandals,
it is briefly beneficial to Vought
to put Starlight front and center
to make them look progressive.
Again, they are using
the power of the media
to create a regime of truth
that helps maintain their position.
But when Homelander tears up the ratings
with a maniacal rant about
his own innate superiority,
fascism comes right back into fashion.
- I am done apologizing,
I am done being persecuted
for my strengths.
You people should be thanking Christ
that I am who and what I am,
because you need me!
You need me to save you!
You do.
I am the only one who possibly can.
- And none of this
would've shocked Deleuze,
who said that "Fascism too,
"one must say that it has assumed
"the social desires,
"including the desires
of repression and death.
"People got hard-ons for Hitler,
"for the beautiful fascist machine."
Though, now it's not hard-ons for Hitler,
but hard-ons for Homelander.
And kids, if you thought
philosophy was boring,
that's a famous French philosopher
who wrote the line,
"People got hard-ons for Hitler."
So major in philosophy,
the one major where you can write a paper
that says the phrase "hard-ons for Hitler"
and not get sent to the counseling center.
The overarching message of
The Boys' third season is
that the capitalist
power structure can adapt
to just about anything.
In most cases, it can
even absorb it outright
and find a way to make money off of it.
The sick genius of capitalism,
according to Deleuze and Guattari,
is that since it's fundamentally
about the logic of power and desire,
and not ethics or ideologies,
it can suck up anything into its orbit
as long as it can help increase profits.
Whether it's A-Train's cynical attempt
to use the Black Lives Matter movement
to propel himself back into relevancy,
or the way Vought turns on a dime
from forcing Maeve to
cover up her sexuality
to using her to rainbow-wash
the company's image,
even the things which
were specifically created
to curtail their power can be sucked up
into the big machine and spat back out
as consumer products.
Starlight realizes this
when Neuman offers her
the latest in a long line
of "ends justify the
means" type propositions.
She's sick of being drawn
into a rigged game
and vows to fight from
the outside instead.
Like one of Deleuze's
favorite literary characters,
Melville's "Bartleby, the Scrivener,"
rather than playing along,
Starlight simply says...
- [Bartleby] I would prefer not to.
- [Michael] And rejects the system.
She also rejects a more
sovereign view of power
when she uses her Instagram Live
to wield power through knowledge
and media influence.
She realizes it's entirely possible
that our French friends were right,
that there is no real outside
and no way to challenge a system
as deeply ingrained as
the one Vought represents,
but she's sure as hell gonna try.
- I'm (beep) done.
I'm not doing it anymore.
- You're not gonna be doing anything
if Homelander kills you.
- Yeah, maybe.
But then, I'll know I'm not working
with a (beep) nut job.
- Of course, whether she'll
be successful is unclear.
We already know that incremental
solutions just won't work,
that the whole system is broken
and needs to be completely rebuilt.
So long as their lives are defined
by a desire for power,
they'll only be safe once they have it.
And that's the lesson which everyone
from Huey to Starlight has been beaten
over the head with
throughout the third season.
And while our friends don't
magically dismantle the economic
and psychic hold of capitalism
by season's end,
we do see some rejections
of the illogical logic of the system.
Huey realizes how utterly effed up
his search for power in the Temp V was.
And by reflecting on his
father's love for him,
he realizes that actual strength comes
from taking care of those we love.
- You know what?
Dad was there,
taking care of me during
the worst days of his life,
just trying to keep the lights on
and a roof above our heads.
- [Michael] This enables
him to throw away the Temp V
and use his not-decaying brain
to very literally empower Starlight
to fight fascism.
And in doing so,
this shows that Huey is rejecting
a sort of old school
sovereign view of power
and enacting a sort of power
that he has some control over.
And we see Maeve seemingly
sacrifice her life
to protect others.
But none of these virtuous
or just acts take place
within the system of Vought's
superhero-industrial complex.
It's not enough to just get
some of the right people
further up the pyramid.
They won't have any more effect on it
than the people sitting
next to Homelander.
It's about pulling the blocks out
from the very bottom
and watching it collapse
so that we can build something new.
But as we see in Homelander's
once good natured son, Ryan,
some people can't help but be attracted
to the power promised by the system.
In its exploration of power,
both at the biological level of supes
who can dominate the rest of humanity
and at the level of a larger system
which runs on the cold logic of capital,
The Boys seems to be pointing to the way
in which our own world
isn't all that different.
Sure, we don't have magical juice
that we can shoot up
to help us teleport in the buff,
or superhumans who can laser-decapitate
a protestor with impunity,
but we do have corporations working
alongside the government
to profit off weapons and power,
social and political figures tapping
into populist anger,
folks from across the
identity spectrum climbing
the corporate ladder and crushing
the folks below them on the way up,
and politicians who are
maybe more into good PR...
- That's why I proposed and the House,
Nancy put it in the plan,
to immediately provide
$10,000 in debt relief
as stimulus right now.
- Than they are actually doing the stuff
they promised to do when we elected them.
And much like the show itself,
we're left wondering if those of us
without any type of superpower,
whether that be strength,
money, or influence,
are left to get, symbolically at least,
run over by those in power.
But what do you guys think?
Is this sort of imbalance
just a fact of life
or can we ever hope to change things?
Let us know what you
think in the comments.
Big thanks to all our
patrons for your support.
Please, don't forget to check out
our new Patriot features,
if you haven't already.
And check out our new
stream, Wisecrack Live,
taking place right here,
Thursdays at 11:00 AM.
Hit that like button like
you're slamming closed
a copy of "Lean In,"
and don't forget to ring
that bell and subscribe.
As always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(upbeat music)
But if you know someone,
or if you or a loved
one have been kidnapped
or murdered by Sheryl Sandberg,
shout it out in the comments.